our next speaker is Richard Allen of UC
Berkeley his PhD at Princeton I believe
owes everything I'm sure to post doc at
Celtic and is now the director of the
system illogical laboratory here great
thank you so it was interesting listen
to Harvey's talk you know in seismology
we used to think of ourselves as being
big data users and it's impossible to
make that statement following the talk
that we just heard this morning we are
very small data users i guess but i
think what i want to talk about what i
want to emphasize is the fact that we
because we are now starting to collect a
lot more data than we were we're sort of
starting to try and think about other
ways of analyzing the data much like
Harvey was talking about and about using
these various machine learning
techniques in order to do that and I am
not the person that knows how to do that
so I'm just going to put our problem in
front of this group and I'm hoping that
somebody will figure out how to to help
us do a much better job than we are
currently doing so I'm going to talk
about what's sort of a new effort in
seismology to provide warnings
earthquake early warnings and I'm going
to talk about it in two contexts one is
what we're actually already now doing
today which is using traditional seismic
networks but then I want to talk about
what i think is coming along which is
sort of massively more data very noisy
data the usual kind of characteristics
that i'm sure this group hears from a
lot of people okay so when I talk about
warnings warnings when you need them in
the context of earthquakes I I guess I'm
not sure maybe half the people in the
rumor from the west coast and half of
the people in the room from the east
coast so for those who are in the east
coast this is what we're concerned about
so we we are concerned about earthquakes
obviously up and down the west coast
we're very fortunate in this country
that we have building codes that mean
the building should not collapse so if
we have an earthquake while you're here
this week you're unlikely to die is the
good news the catch is is that the
insides of the buildings are not
necessarily built to similar kinds of
standards and I
have to say when I look at the ceiling
tiles for this particular room it's
particularly alarming and so when we
talk about warnings when you start to
feel shaking what you should be doing a
quick quick recap for earthquake safety
if the ground starts to shake you get
down behind the chair in front of you
and the reason is that these ceiling
tiles are going to fall down if they hit
you on the head they could do some
serious damage so when we're talking
about warnings we're talking about using
a few seconds to take protective
measures so that you don't get injured
in an earthquake and so this would be
one example this is another example
closer to home we had a earthquake in
Napa almost two years ago I guess now
and it was a small earthquake it was
only a magnitude 6 those one fatality
but things like this fireplace is
falling down so we we know how to build
buildings that don't collapse but still
we get a lot of injuries and we expect
to get a lot of injuries in earthquakes
and that's one of the applications of
warnings going to other parts of the
world this is Nepal last year in the
pool of course other parts of the world
do not have the building standards that
were fortunate to have here and so you
get much wider spread damage and much
larger number of fatalities and again
having warnings in the case of Nepal we
estimate they could have had about 20
seconds of warning in there in the
Katmandu in Katmandu for these
earthquakes in the pool taiwan even
places that have really good building
codes taiwan has excellent building
codes they don't always do their job as
you can see here and so just increasing
people's awareness of the hazards
associated with earthquakes is another
piece and that ties in to using mobile
technology to provide the warnings it
also provides an opportunity to educate
people about this and finally sort of
remember oculus the number of scenarios
when people could use a warning when
there's going to be an earthquake this
is damage to the road from the Napa
earthquake of course aftershocks are
very common after earthquakes
aftershocks move the same fractures that
were caused by the earthquake this is a
really foolish thing to be doing
immediately after an earthquake just in
case you didn't know okay so those are
just to give you some example of the
warnings
that we're talking about as I mentioned
the very beginning I want to do a
two-pronged approach I want to start by
talking about shake alert shake alert is
what I'll call a proven technology this
is using traditional seismic networks to
deliver warnings and we're getting very
close to having a public warning system
on the west coast of the United States
so I want to introduce the topic by
giving you a quick overview of what
shake alert is about but most of the
time I'm going to spend talking about a
new effort that we have to use
smartphones to actually record
earthquake shaking so using the sensors
on the smart phones to record shaking
we're interested in doing it to generate
a whole new sort of seismic global
seismic network to collect data for all
kinds of research but why would you put
the app on your phone well one reason
would be because that way you'll get
earthquake early warning so the
objective of my shake is to collect data
for all kinds of research but one of
those pieces is earthquake early warning
and that's why we believe many people
will put the app on their phone okay so
what is earthquake early warning just to
give you a slightly better sense and
that the amount of time we're talking
about this is the real time cartoon of
the most damaging earthquake for us here
in the San Francisco Bay Area this is
going to be a magnitude eight earthquake
on the San Andreas Fault it started up
here this brown swath is the actual
rupture then it's going to come all the
way down the San Andreas Fault past the
Bay Area and stop right about here the
circles are the energy that's radiating
out from the fault during the earthquake
the yellow circles are the p-waves they
travel fastest okay so they arrive first
but they don't have very much energy
associated with them so right about now
is when we would feel the first p wave
and this is a big earthquake we would
feel it we would all look at one another
and we would wonder what's going on
after a few seconds we would know this
is an earthquake but we would assume
that this is a moderate-sized earthquake
somewhere in the Bay Area we would have
no idea it's just the P wave for what is
a truly massive earthquake it's only
when the S waves represented by the red
circles that travel about half the speed
so anyone the S waves start to arrive
that you start to see strong shaking so
now is when we would know that the
was really a very large earthquake and
if you weren't already on the floor you
would all be on the floor by now and
wondering what was going to happen next
but still the strongest shaking hasn't
started okay the strongest shaking here
in Berkeley will occur when the fault
ruptures closest to us so this is the
section of the fault that's closest to
us so it's only when this rupture occurs
right here that we would start to feel
the very strongest period of shaking
it's more than two minutes after the
beginning of this particular earthquake
again this is running in real time so
this just illustrates that there's
actually a lot of time during the course
of an earthquake okay and that's the
time that we want to take advantage of
in order to provide earthquake early
warning but clearly to do that we have
to be able to process whatever data we
have in real time very rapidly in order
to push warnings out to two people that
that might be an arms way right now is
when the strongest shaking would be
starting right here and the strongest
shaking is going to go on for about
another 30 seconds or so before it's
done okay so this is the worst case
earthquake for the San Francisco Bay
Area it also happens to be the best case
scenario in terms of the amount of
warning time as in the maximum amount of
warning time maybe a minute a minute and
a half worth of warning is what we might
expect for this event more more
realistic estimates of warning times for
the more frequent earthquakes and that
might occur close by are seconds to tens
of seconds okay the amount of warning
time is a simple function of our
distance from the epicenter of the
earthquake if the earthquake starts
closer by there's less warning time okay
so that's the idea behind earthquake
early warning ya 19 United quake
computers would
sure yeah so if I go back the 19 18 yet
and please do stop me with questions
because yeah so the nineteen eighty nine
earthquake the Loma Prieta earthquake
which was the last sort of major
damaging earthquake here in the Bay Area
ruptured this section of the San Andreas
Fault right here okay it was a magnitude
6.9 earthquake with a it's about a
hundred kilometers from San Francisco
Berkeley Oakland area and so with about
a hundred kilometers and the system i'm
going to show you you'd have about 20
seconds of warning that's what we'd get
in a repeat p waves and S waves physical
constants that are uniform for always
yeah so the pns waves the P waves travel
at about six and a half kilometers per
second the S waves travel at about three
and a half kilometers per second because
they do vary slightly they depends on
the subsurface conditions but only small
amounts yeah so that's right so that's
kind of so that's fixed so predicting
when the shaking is going to arrive is
easy the the challenge is recognizing
when the earthquake starts and doing it
very quickly so using as little data as
possible to know that there's an
earthquake and Estes to estimate the
size of the earthquake as accurately as
possible those are the challenges yeah I
like you this for now feels that you
know a day ahead there will be a nice
way well you have some level bug that
this will be physically possible it's
well I won't say it's impossible I will
say I don't most seismologists don't see
it in the foreseeable future so so what
you just described a day ahead is what
we would call earthquake prediction what
I'm talking about is earthquake warning
and the difference is for warnings the
earthquake itself has begun underground
so the earthquake rupture has nucleated
on the fault surface and that's why
we're talking about seconds to minutes
to actually do that a day ahead you have
to predict when the rupture is going to
start underground and that's so that's
obviously very different set of physics
very complex physics that most
seismologists degree we're not going to
be able to predict that in the future
yeah i just downloaded the my shape
thanks for excellent but they also have
something called earthquake lord is that
something from headed around do you know
if you but i can't remember there are so
many earthquake apps there's nothing
that does what my shake does i can say
that much I can't remember specifically
the app you're talking about to be
honest but see it's got the same
braiding oh and I thought we had a good
rating well okay full with it y'all well
I'll explain what we're not doing with
our app yet is we're jumping ahead a
little here but that's okay is actually
providing warnings now when we actually
start to provide warnings either the
rating could go up or it could go down a
lot depending on how successful we are
right yeah I know but there are no other
app that's trying to do what my shake is
doing right now is they're providing
warning why don't you ask me that
question at the end okay and then we
show you where we are and then i'll show
you sort of set up an example scenario
where the quick starts somewhere on the
4th and propagates along the part good
is that the way we should all imagine
most big earthquakes or can they be some
kind of random not following the fault
line kind of earthquake no i mean big
earthquakes when i say big earthquakes i
mean something bigger than a magnitude 7
they they have to rupture some
significant length of fault to get to be
that big right the magnitude of the
earthquake is actually related to the
area of the fault that's rupturing okay
so up to once you get to about to
magnitude 7 you actually have to have
some finite extent we think of them as
being finite fault you can sort of treat
small events as point sources and so so
it's quite possible they'll will rupture
on an unknown fault but for big
earthquakes like that they we have no
real evidence of the whole question
about how you create new Pfalz let me
put it like that is unclear so for the
sake of thinking about hazards in the
future we can think about big
earthquakes rupturing on on known faults
and then in other tectonic environments
where the faults are buried we may not
be able to see the fault we may not know
exactly where the fault is but we know
the type of fault that's there
yeah since the falls are so localized
does the make sense to have sensors done
in service so the Berkeley sighs my lab
run seismic networks most of them are at
the surface but we do also have borehole
sensors but most borehole sensors are
still just a few hundred meters below
the surface so that's sort of I mean
it's good because it reduces noise
seismic noise on the sensor but it's not
like you're really getting that much
closer to the fault to give you some
scale in in san fran in california where
the faults are strike-slip type of
faults for those you remember your plate
tectonics the plates are moving
horizontally and so we have strike-slip
faults the actual rupture rate-- extends
from the surface down to about 10 12
kilometers depth okay so that's the
fault plane ten kilometers in depth and
then up to hundreds of kilometers inland
so you know going down a few hundred
meters it's really just scratching the
surface okay please keep them coming
mrs. that's great okay so who would use
earthquake early warning well the idea
is to reduce hazards falling hazards
that's the ceiling tiles example I gave
you just to put some numbers on it in
loma prieta fifty percent of the
injuries were caused by these kinds of
falls in northridge again more than
fifty percent of the injuries were
created by non-structural falling
hazards and so two big IFS if everybody
receives a few seconds of warning and if
everybody uses it to to take action and
then you could read you could reduce the
number of injuries in an earthquake by
fifty percent okay now this is a big
deal even in Northridge Northridge was
not a big earthquake north which was a
moderate sized earthquake most of the
shaking was not in the urban environment
just like North red and just like Matt
loma prieta but the estimated cost of
just the injuries is 2 to 3 billion
dollars so if we can have that that's a
significant saving using
but the other applications are automated
control slowing and stopping trains
those of you who live in the Bay Area or
use the BART train while you're here but
already gets our warnings and
automatically stops the trains even
though it's a demonstration system right
now so they are so concerned about what
will happen to their trains derailment
type of scenarios that they want to slow
and stop the trains stopping elevators
it's estimated several thousand people
will be trapped in elevators in the next
big earthquake in San Francisco Bay Area
hazardous machinery chemicals data
security etc exception just I want to
give you a flavor of why we're doing
this yep I was in Japan and met some
days of the latrine the Shinkansen they
said that the never had dreamed jumping
tracks and they have done some amazing
design of the system first of all it's
not true they've never had trains jump
the tracks two trains have come off the
tracks but in both cases it wasn't a
serious it wasn't a catastrophic
derailment in both cases they literally
did just jump the tracks and so they may
even have been no injuries so they do
have I don't want to diminish they have
a spectacular safety record part of it
is that they have engineered the bullet
train system to really withstand shaking
in the first place that's the equivalent
of building buildings that don't fall
down the second piece is that they have
only one in Japan has a nationwide
Public earthquake early warning system
they've had it since 2007 the bullet
trains have had it since they were first
built in their 60s or 70s that we go and
and so as soon as they see any kind of
earthquake that's going on they the
trains start to slow and stop exactly
the same reason that Bart jumped on this
as soon as we started to experiment
ok and then how will you get earthquake
early warning well one obvious way of
course is everybody has one of these
devices in their pocket right now I'm so
world quick one and yah go cover and
hold on strong shaking expected very
simple very simple message earthquakes
coming duck cover and hold on the an app
that can show a countdown and there's
this particular version this is actually
a real app so i actually have this app
on my phone no it's not publicly
available this is still a project that's
we have test users like bart now but
it's not a publicly available kind of
thing but a small group of people get
these get these kinds of warning this is
a this is feasible okay we can actually
do this this technology exists it's just
about taking this and turning it into a
full-blown public system again this is
the system using the traditional seismic
network and we have apps via computer
the whole idea is you would push this
warning out through any kind of
communication channel that you can yeah
can i point out that there were small
absolutely you can okay so the
technology exists and just to kind of
conclude this to show that this is
possible i'm going to have somebody else
show you that the technology exists
misty digital communications travel at
the speed of light bench the things like
fiber optic cable you can move
information literally in a flash and
that is good just in the abstract but
that is if it turns out potentially
life-saving if the information that you
are moving at the speed of light is
notification that an earthquake is about
to happen earthquakes happen in a
specific place in the ground right
earthquakes have an epicenter but you
don't just feel it or a quake at the
epicenter the shuttering waves of motion
in the earth from earthquake they
emanate out from the epicenter of the
quake traveling at the speed of saved so
if you have the kind of motion sensors
that detected earthquakes if you had
seismometers along fault lines all over
earthquake prone regions when there was
an earthquake the seismometers nearest
to the epicenter they could register
that an earthquake has happened right
field the shake and then they could send
a digital signal at the speed of light
notifying community is nearby that this
traveling at the speed of sound tremor
this motion of the earth is about to
arrive this is not a way of predicting
earthquakes before they happen it's a
Bay it's a way of basically warning
people that an earthquake has just
happened and that they are about to feel
its effects brace yourself but this
thing works scientists at UC Berkeley
say that their shake alert to earthquake
early warning project it set off an
alert it didn't go off this weekend
during this weekend's large quake in
Napa California it was about to be felt
in Berkeley and this is the alert that
told them so watch this
earthquake earthquake like shaking
expected in three seconds they got a 10
second morning that they were about to
feel the quake in 10 seconds is not much
time right but this this brace yourself
warning system it works thanks to the
simple fact that the speed of light is
faster than the speed of sound and
earthquakes only move at this beam set
with more sensors in more places they
could presumably deliver even more
warning time California's hoping to have
that bigger system in place in the next
few years if they can get it funded and
finished from the LA Times today once
fully developed the system could give
downtown Los Angeles 40 to 50 seconds of
warning that the big one was headed from
the San Andreas Fault giving time for
elevators to stop at the next floor and
open up for firefighters to open up
garage doors for high-speed trains to
slow down to avoid derailment and for
surgeons to take the scuffle out of a
patient's giving your surgeon enough
time to get the scalpel out of you
before the giant earthquakes start
shaking the operating room that idea of
a tectonic Lee shaking scuffle inside
your body somewhere that is something
you can never unknow and I'm sorry but
the idea that this morning technology
that it works and it worked this weekend
in fact it's not just not a drawing
board somewhere it is in effect and it
could be expanded and is being expanded
that is an excellent thing they've got a
system like this in Japan they've gotten
in Mexico and some other places around
the globe California could get their
whole statewide system done in a few
years god bless the geeks they will save
us all now it's time for the last word
with lawrence O'Donnell highlights
Rachel I just want me to make the
earthquake warning voice a little less
scary
take Rachel great little summary of what
we're doing except for his comment of
course I think we wanted to be scary you
want people to pay attention but this
obviously is you put this together after
the the napper earthquake but again this
is just to kind of illustrate I mean
it's great you know we spend I don't
know how many years trying to work on
this project and she condenses the value
of it into just three minutes in a very
entertaining and amusing way it was a
very very nice piece the point is it
works okay we can do this but of course
we would like it to be better than it is
it is right now finally before I start
talking about the cell phones to give
you a sense of that traditional
coseismic network I keep talking about
these are the sensors that we use the in
Southern California Northern California
Oregon and Washington and then we also
stream data in from from Canada and
Mexico are for obvious reasons to the
north and the south so right now today
there's about 800 traditional seismic
stations that stream their data in
real-time into our system we detect
earthquakes on individual waveforms we
then we recognize when we see clusters
of triggers we recognize as as
earthquakes estimate the location the
magnitudes and push the warnings out and
the groups that are getting the warnings
right now there's about 75 institutions
it's probably closer to 100 actually now
but to give you a sense emergency
response groups at state city levels
power utility companies Bart I already
mentioned biotech companies Google of
course they were one of the first groups
that just wanted the data other Intel
Microsoft groups like this so that the
point is that the the point is that this
system this traditional system it's
coming and I can tell you if that the
governor has to sign the state's budget
today in case you didn't know that very
important and in fact that will include
10 million dollars to start rolling out
the public earthquake early warning
system in California okay so that's the
traditional system traditional network
this is what's next and this is the
piece that was sort of struggling with
when it comes to figuring out how to
handle the data and so as you just saw
in in with my wits I shake alert the
whole
idea is that we would push the warning
out to people on their cell phone so
that's obviously sending a message to
you on your phone the whole point of my
shake is we actually want to use the
accelerometer that's in your phone to
also detect the earthquake in the first
place so we want this to become the
seismic sensor in addition to being the
mechanism by which we might push a
warning out to you so how would this
work well you have thousands potentially
millions of smartphones across an
earthquake prone region that are running
the app the my shake-app and they're
looking for the right trying to
characterize the motion all the time and
when they when you see a cluster all
recognizing an earthquake we send that
information to a a server that's based
in the cloud for real-time analysis and
we detect that there's actually an
earthquake that is underway okay and so
this is the piece as I said at the
beginning that we think will drive
people being willing to run the app on
their phone and put the app for that
matter on their phone in the first place
but for us the objectives are much
broader this is about collecting the
data collecting the seismic data the
actual acceleration data from the phone
retrieving that from the phones putting
it in storage and then we can use that
for all the kinds of research activities
that we use traditional seismic networks
and possibly many more courses are very
different much larger and kind of data
set so that's the idea behind behind my
shake now what are the challenges with
this there are some significant
challenges with this the first is that
the most serious ground shaking on the
most serious shaking i should say your
phone experiences is not an earthquake
ok this is stronger than an earthquake
shaking typically all right so the
amplitude of the shaking that is
observed on your phone during most
earthquakes at least is significantly
lower than what you subject your phone
to every single day so we have to be
able to separate our earthquakes from
all of the other shaking they're much
more frequent shaking type of events and
so this was why this is what brought us
into this whole question of the very
different type of data analysis to what
we are seismologists are you
too and so we developed this approach
where we is a basically a classifier
analysis we we came up with a whole
array of different characteristics we
identified the three characteristics on
the the acceleration that allow us to
most clearly separate earthquake shakes
shown in red from non earthquake shakes
shown in blue and using a newer network
classifier and we do this on to second
chunks of data so this runs on your
phone it's analyzing every two second
chance of data it's calculating these
characteristics seeing where where it
falls and if it thinks it's an
earthquake if it falls into this region
here then it triggers and it sends that
information just the trigger time and
the location of the phone to to our
central server and it's remarkably
successful in our testing before we
rolled out the public app we found that
it was accurate ninety-three percent of
the time so that was that's really very
encouraging this is just on one phone ok
so the axes IQR is interquartile range
and so this is essentially a measure of
the amplitude is I'm sort of almost
embarrassed to describe this to you this
is very basic so this is just an inter
quartile range and then this is the zero
crossing just a simple count of the
number of times the the trace crosses
zero basically a frequency measure so
this is a frequency measure this is an
amplitude measure with there's a third
one we identified the top three and I
honestly can't remember what the third
one was it was significantly less
important than these two is intent oh
yeah this is for a single vote for a
single accelerometer absolutely it's
amazing but I would think that the the
most useful thing would be the fact for
example of all of us were to accelerate
in the same way of B is that in fact the
collected data from a collection of
accelerometers would be much much more
million you have exactly right give me
two slides
what does ninety-three percent success
fee does that mean when what about yeah
yeah I know ok so the ninety-three
percent success so of course we did a
whole bunch of tests one test was we had
a forerunner of this app on 75 student
phones actually here on campus and they
were had a very simple st alt a trigger
algorithm they were triggering all the
time sending five minutes of data to our
back-end server or four months a big big
non earthquake data set so and then we
had for the earthquake data set we had
two types of data we actually put an
array of about twenty smartphones on a
shake table an engineering shake table
what they used to test buildings and
recorded earthquakes that was our
earthquake data we also took data from
traditional seismic networks and
degraded it so it looks more like cell
phone data we adding noise reducing that
and so so the way we would develop this
is that we we took we drew data from
both of those data sets for the
classifier analysis this ninety-three
percent success rate the two numbers
were 93 and 96 and I may have the two
the wrong way around and I forget
whether this is the ninety-three percent
success rate on non earthquake data and
96 on earthquake data or vice versa it
doesn't really
actually it does not because if you have
a lot more events that are sort of
possible earthquakes than real
earthquakes then it doesn't matter
because the most important step is the
next step all right and so if as long as
we are doing a reasonably good job of
recognizing some earthquake on the phone
the next step is the real determining
step that's why it doesn't okay so to
give you a sense right so the whole idea
this is on one phone so that your phone
thinks it's seeing an earthquake it
sends a trigger to to the central server
and just to give you a sense of you know
what the this the of what that looks
like with the data here's an example
this is a real earthquake this this is
actually the Napa earthquake recorded on
a phone oh no sorry this is a this is a
on the traditional network with phone
noise added but this just shows you the
classifier analysis no earthquake no
earthquake no earthquake earthquake
earthquake earthquake no earthquake and
then here's a much longer time series
300 seconds this is one of those non
earthquake samples and you know it's
classifying that it's not an earthquake
most of the time just give you sis ok so
now another phone thinks it's seeing
earthquake we now need to confirm that
that earthquake is underway and we do
that by simply recognizing a spacetime
cluster and this is even simpler or even
more embarrassing that it's so simple
than the on phone kind of application
because all we're doing right now is
looking for a number of phones to
trigger within small space and time
small space and time being 10 kilometers
I believe we're looking for within 10
seconds or 20 seconds to give you a
sense but that's all very basic but it
actually works remarkably well this is
still a simulation we actually have a
public version of the app and i'm going
to show you data from that in a minute
this is from pre-release simulation of
that and again this is taking
traditional seismic network so this is
i'm going to show you data from
magnitude 5 earthquake in the los
angeles area so this is the traditional
seismic network that been down grounded
downgraded but then we applied our
algorithms to it so we applied the on
phone algorithm to recognize when one of
these simulated phones seized an
earthquake and then we plot apply our
detection algorithm which is very basic
and i'm just going to play this video
and you can see how it does
yeah is the energy drained from the
accelerometer small enough that people
can keep the great question right I mean
I'm a seismologist and all of a sudden I
have to worry about how do you get
people to put an app on their phone and
the thing you immediately learn is that
the key thing is it can in no way
interfere with what people actually have
the phone for and the number one way
that you do that is you kill their
battery before the end of the day so our
design criteria was that the app has to
you or should use no more than the same
amount of power that your phone is using
when it's not doing anything right so
when my phones in my pocket it's still
doing a low level processes and our
design criterias we wanted to be at
about the same level we actually didn't
quite get to that point but we did get
to the point where most modern phones
for most typical users you can be
running this app on your phone all day
and you still just have to charge your
phone once a day which is what most
people do on us but that's some that's
an area that we still actually want to
reduce power okay so let me run this
simulation for the La Habra earthquake
when it turns pink it's when the phone
triggers when the blue star appears it's
when the detection algorithm recognize
there was an event sort of moves around
as it kind of relocates the event with
time the initiative think that the
initial magnitude estimate was 5.0 are
played again in a second was 5.0 it
actually does a remarkably good job this
was kind of a proof of concept stage of
the whole project oh here we go again so
the first 45 seconds of a magnitude 5.2
and we can compare how this performance
this has gained simulated performance
and so we can compare that to the actual
performance of shake alert the the real
warning system that I showed you a few
minutes ago I'm actually very similar
5.3 seconds after the origin time five
seconds magnitude 4.3 5.2 so this is
quite remarkable this gave us this is
why we decided to proceed we feel like
this system can actually do something
similar to the traditional network yeah
so is the information being sent
phone simply one bit which is I did
think I detect an earthquake and then
give the onset time the timestamp yeah
it's so the the two types of data that
comes actually as well there's three
types of data comes in phones when a
phone triggers it immediately sends I've
triggered here's my trigger time and
here's my location okay some other book
yeah it then it records a total of five
minutes worth of data so it has a ring
buffer of one minute so we have one
minute before the trigger and five
minutes four minutes after and then the
other is a heartbeat informations of a
state of health we need to know how many
phones alive so that we can make this
algorithm work a key part to this is you
need to know you know you want some
proportion of your phones to have
triggered so you made the comment well
if everybody's phone moves at the same
time in this room well that just means I
just you know everybody stood up to
cheer because I scored a goal right see
ya so the this whole question about how
you separate out real earthquakes from
other kinds of activities like that is
is one of the remaining challenges but
but this space just on the fact that the
trigger occurred and now you're looking
at just clusters of triggers yeah and so
the other piece is right we're looking
for cluster of triggers in space and
time and we look for more than I forget
now fifty percent of the phones that are
active to have triggered and that's why
we need the heartbeat information so we
have some sense of how many phones or
running the system at acceleration
traces no because they take much longer
so by just sending that small packet of
information we get it in for most cases
a few milliseconds soon as you start to
send waveforms it's slower although in
the future you know we might be
so going back to the original
classifications of each phone gasps
don't earth-based come in different have
different features does a frequency and
amplitude and so on I do you had this
cutoff this high frequency something
it's actually low frequency it was it
was long periods right it was it was
longer periods to the right and so the
and it wasn't the highest amplitude but
it also wasn't the lowest amplitudes
either right so it was long periods and
these intermediate amplitudes that that
are characteristic so of course there's
some sensitivity here to the magnitude
of the event so this aann trigger will
only work we would expect it to work for
larger events we also expected it only
to detect the s-wave arrival that
stronger shaking phase but I'm about to
start showing you data and it's yep
going back to Jake's question which is
good about the power do you have any
ability in your application to kind of
turn it off put it it quiet for a while
because you're referring too much powder
absolutely so when I forget what the
number is but when the battery goes
below some level it turns itself off
automatically I mean you have a huge
sample potentially you might want to
turn a lot of them are just so that they
ran whistle message so what I haven't
said at all here is that this project is
actually a collaboration between the
Berkeley sighs my lab and deutsche
telekom and deutsche telekom are
interested in this well there's all well
I think one of the official reasons
deutsche telekom are interested in this
is because they're interested in the
whole networking problem flash mob type
situation where you have a lot of phones
that are all detecting and all want to
send information managing the network
turning phones on and off in an
intelligent way for exactly the reasons
you just described ok this is just to
show the sort of noise floor of the
phone and compare it to to earthquake so
the dashed lines here are the typical
amplitudes for different magnitude
earthquakes at 10 kilometers so
magnitude 2.5 up to like a 6.5 7.5 and
then the colored lines are the noise
floors of the phones and so this is when
we would you know tells us what kind of
earthquakes we would expect and so again
our conclusion was that we would be able
to record magnitude 5 earthquakes at 10
kilometers grade again this was our
pitch before we rolled out the
the app we rolled out the app in
February i'm going to show you what we
found since in a moment this is what a
traditional seismic net station noise
sensor noise level looks like so much
much lower of course but this is also
another mem sense this is a very high
quality MEMS sensor I mean we don't
expect this to ever be in phones but the
point is we only expect the sensors to
get better in phones and so you know
whatever we can do today can be able to
do more tomorrow usually refrain ok I'm
not going to go through this my shake
isn't going to replace traditional
seismic networks I don't want people to
think they shouldn't fun traditional
seismic networks because we have cell
phones that would be very foolish and so
please nobody take that away from this
talk but the point is that traditional
seismic networks only exist in a few
parts of the world ok that Network I
showed you on the west coast of the US
really there's only the west coast of
the u.s. and Japan that have networks
like that the most the majority of
places around the world with significant
seismic hazard all of the red regions on
this map have very few traditional
seismic stations but I don't need to
tell you how pervasive smart phones have
become and they're only ever getting
more pervasive this brings us back to
this Nepal example that I showed you at
the beginning they had to magnitude
eight ish earthquakes last year I'm
causing a lot of damage and a large
number of fatalities I actually tried to
figure out how many seismic stations
that were in Nepal and the conclusion
was about to plus or minus 4 okay it's
incredibly unclear how many instruments
that are in the pool however it is
clearly very small alright but there are
six million smartphones in the poor
alright in Katmandu alone there are
about 600,000 ok so again this is kind
of why we think there's real potential
here ok so this is where we are you just
downloaded the app you obviously have an
android phone so here's the catch we
only have it for android phones right
now and the reason is that there are
many more android phones around the
world than there are iphones it's just a
question of resources to develop an
iphone version ok so if you download the
app today you do not get earthquake
early warning just to be clear ok what
you do is you you'll learn about the
act our past earthquakes you know
hopefully we can help educate people so
people will be better prepared for
future earthquakes so right now this is
a citizen science projects right I'm
asking you to put the app on your phone
to contribute to the science that we're
doing there's no early warning right now
and so this is just running through what
you can see you get all the kind of
information you'll get from any
earthquake app you'll get from this app
the difference is that this app will
also actually provide us with data about
about the earthquakes and of course
obviously the idea is that we can do
something interesting with this now but
in the future we could actually start to
provide an earthquake alerts okay
alright so the launch so that you know
we we had it on sythe inc i said earlier
75 phones and we decided okay we should
try and roll this out and see whether we
can get any interest so we planned a
public rollout we we were hoping we had
it on 75 phones we were hoping to get it
on or maybe a thousand phones we decided
to plan big so we got ready for what we
thought we could handle 10,000 phones
and we rolled it out and in the first
weekend we had 60,000 phones download
and with the completely global coverage
as you can see here from this map we
would just expect him to get interest in
the US so that was great I mean there
was a huge amount of interest in it this
was back in February so today there are
about 40,000 phones that have the app on
them and on any particular day about
11,000 phones are actually communicating
with our system right and this is six
months later so we're quite pleased with
that though clearly we have to start
worrying about how we maintain this and
potentially build and build the number
of users but this is this is actually
the largest global seismic Network by a
long long way right now yeah thousands
well be how many are you see Bay Area I
think actually i'm going to show you
that hang on one second i think i have a
map coming up so this is what number
around the world united states is pretty
high we really wanted to have a big
rollout in japan because they have a lot
of earthquakes but we actually have a
lat japan japanese language version as
well but we're really struggling sort of
interesting you know there's interest in
some parts of the world and not in other
parts of the world so we're trying to
understand that here's the our answer
for the bay area so of the 11,000 about
1200 are in the bay area in about 2100
or in the Los Angeles area and so here's
I didn't if you can read the numbers on
this map but so the red are the hundreds
and the I the orange of the tens
actually put this map together last week
and so this is actually the number of
phones that were active on life forget
what day Wednesday of last week and then
this is across the East Bay where we are
right now
and you can see slightly higher cluster
in Berkeley but not that much higher
than everywhere else so you know it's
really was quite really quite pleased
obviously and so now we're actually
starting to get oh sorry yeah so again
with the real-time server the real-time
detection service re is now operating
but it's not working properly we we've
run into all kinds of technical
challenges okay let me start there and
we are first focus when we rolled it out
was to deal with the technical
challenges on the phone not the
technical challenges associated with the
server so the server is running but it's
not it's not doing a very good job of
detecting earthquakes at all so I can
only answer your question based on our
simulations before the rollout and based
on our simulations we estimated that you
needed about 300 phones within a 100
kilometers by 100 kilometers area so we
clearly exceed that but who knows this
is the real world not the simulated
world so we suspect that we can do a
reasonably good job with this this
number of phones but were worsted we're
just not at that we've been clinging on
by our fingernails since we rolled out
please so this may be a long question
but our answer to the question but what
are the technical challenge you've run
into bids to arm it I mean oh it's like
it's like it's like going back in
starting seismology all over again the
first thing we all had to relearn is
time really matters okay and so getting
as accurate time as possible timestamps
on the way forms that were coming in and
and the triggers for that matter
actually was quite a challenge and it's
surprisingly difficult to a get
reasonably good times when I say good
times you know we're used in seismology
to having things accurate within a few
milliseconds we're not going to get that
kind of accuracy but we've had all kinds
of issues with with time with timestamps
being off by hours I mean all kinds of
thing I mean not complicated stuff that
somebody with the right technical
expertise and just having the time to
put into it can fix those kinds of
challenges well now I'm going to show
you some of the data so we're now at the
stage where we are collecting large
volumes of data and so we can start
dealing with more some of the more real
challenges where we wanted we want to
develop the real-time detection
algorithm to work
properly we want to do a better job of
triggering on phones to give you a sense
a typical phone will trigger about four
times on average will trigger four times
a day so four times a day the phone
thinks it just saw an earthquake when
there was no earthquake okay so the
phone of course is filtering out by you
know the majority of the events but
still we get for triggers from every
phone we have 11,000 phones and so those
are the kinds of issues that will work
okay five minutes yep yeah you've
mentioned it but you're the first one to
think about it you probably make a lot
of money in predictor the ten-second
especially if you call your broker and
oiling down any defecation yeah I mean
yeah I think there's a lot of
applications for earthquake early
warning okay so just to give you a sense
of some of the data is kind of how on a
wrap up you just show you some data so
since we rolled out I mean this I put
this slide together a few weeks ago but
you know we've recorded you know
probably about 150 earthquakes at this
point if you remember I said we are we
were expecting people to be called
magnitude 5 earthquakes we're actually
recording down to magnitude 2.5
earthquakes so we're really quite
pleased with that we're just going to
show you so I'm sort of assuming people
understand what I'm showing when I
showed this this is an acceleration
trace so with the accelerometers in your
phones have three components you know to
two components in the plane of the phone
and one component perpendicular to it
and since it's just the output the
acceleration as a function of time this
is actually the smallest earthquake we
recorded this is a magnitude 2.5 on a
phone that was very close to the
earthquake and you know you can see the
signal-to-noise ratio here is terrible
but still the the aann algorithm
detected that this was an earthquake we
literally have this one trace miss
earthquake but this is just to show you
the lower bound in terms of magnitude
and the upper bound in terms of bad data
okay or poor quality data i should say
we've been we've been surprised at how
many induced earthquakes we've been
recording in oklahoma you may be aware
in
Texas other oil-producing areas they're
having a lot of issues with increased
seismicity there's nobody from the press
here so I will just call them induced
earthquakes and so this is one example
of an induced earthquake this is a very
small magnitude 2.6 earthquake one of
the issues is there's almost no seismic
networks in these parts of the world
because there aren't any tectonic
earthquakes we have hundreds of phones
recording these earthquakes right now
it's some joining for the shoe to fall
on that one because it's racket yeah
yeah to be clear it's not the fracking
that causes the earthquakes when they do
fracking it's taking the fluids that
they use and they pump them down into
waste wells and that's what causes the
earthquakes in soccer okay so this is
the magnitude 2.6 magnitude 5.1 this is
kind of interesting because we also only
ever expected the algorithm to trigger
on p waves as IRS waves the larger
packet this is the P wave you can see
this is also this is that this is one
bit right of signal so this is a very
low sensitivity instrument the zero time
is when the phone triggered so the zero
time is when the phone triggered we then
went back and we identified the
earthquake and this is the predicted p
wave arrival the predicted s-wave
arrival so this is a magnitude 5 event
would the phones are detecting and we're
actually detecting the p ways we never
thought we would actually be able to
detect the p wait we are yeah seems that
you're triggering algorithms are not bad
do you really need algorithmic
innovation huh i think that the real i
think that this kind of let me also i
have a slide at the very end where I'll
answer that question if that's okay let
me keep going and this is Ecuador if you
may remember there was a fairly damaging
earthquake in Ecuador we didn't have a
huge number of phones this is our cell
phone map for that day in Ecuador the
red dots are the phones that were active
but they weren't steady so the phones
there when they're active they wait for
the phone to be steady I you put it down
and then they start monitoring for the
earthquake and so the red ones were not
in steady the orange were in steady but
didn't trigger and the greens were in
steady and did trigger so we just had
two phones trigger for this particular
earthquake but there's some
some distance away this is the this is
the trace from one of those and it's
kind of really interesting so again the
trigger is the zero time okay the green
is the predicted p-wave arrival and the
red is the predicted s-wave arrival so
what actually happened here is and then
this this is the person picking up the
phone so what actually happened here was
the phone was sat on somebody's desk it
triggered on the earthquake recorded the
p-wave arrival it recorded the s-wave
arrival the person felt the earthquake
and picked up their phone okay so this
is them picking up the phone so if i
zoom in all right so P wave arrival if i
zoom in to this region here before they
pick it up just so you can see the data
so this is when the phone triggered this
is the P wave arrival in green and this
is the S wave arrival then they and then
they they picked it up ok and then let's
just go through the rest about this so
Alaska easy just more events from around
the world Taiwan Argentina Japan I mean
just a massive amount of data that we're
now just at the point where we can start
thinking about what we want to do with
it Mexico Nepal okay I'm going to finish
by showing you this this is our best
event so far this was actually not long
ago this is just a few weeks ago June
tenth this is the magnitude 5.2
earthquake in southern california and so
the star here is the location of the
earthquake so unfortunately i'm a
seismologist unfortunately the
earthquake was a long way away from
anybody and so the phones the closest
phones are like 20 or 30 it's only a
five it wouldn't hurt anybody so the the
phones are 20 or 30 kilometers away
again same thing green ones are the
phones that triggered a total of over
700 phones triggered 600 uploaded
waveforms and of those 600 uploaded
waveforms about a hundred were good as
in we can actually see the earthquake we
would actually consider doing something
with those with those waveforms that's
what we mean by good this is just shows
you these are the trigger times of the
network the aann trigger time the blue
is the p-wave arrival the red is the
s-wave arrival so you can see that a lot
of phones triggered on the p a lot of
phones triggered on the s and then
there's some other this is probably just
triggering on the shaking after after
the S wave arrival this is the data
going out to about 100
80 kilometers you can sort of see the
p-wave arrival can see the s-wave
arrival so we're really pleased and this
is just a few days ago right so this
project is really just getting going and
this is you know this is more data than
we have from an earthquake across
Southern California at this point and
then this is just shows you the peak
amplitude one of the issues you look at
with buildings is the peak shaking so as
a function of distances distance this is
the peak ground acceleration obviously
the acceleration goes down as you get
further away the red are the traditional
seismic stations and the blue of the the
smartphone stations and so you know the
data is consistent I mean we're still in
that stage of verifying that we
understand what the data is showing us
this is an example where there was a
phone I think it was a kilometer away
yeah a kilometer away from a traditional
seismic station and you can see that
they're slightly different that's not
surprising there a kilometer away it's
very similar data so we're very we feel
like the quality of the data is pretty
good okay so two dicks question you know
what's the what's the real challenge
here it's sort of as I was thinking
about this this morning I mean the
reality is that the challenges are still
the same challenges that we've always
had with seismology is just we have to
do an even better job than we've done in
the past the first is triggering on
earthquake signals so dick asked you
know it doesn't seem like you have a
problem triggering but the issue is that
we do have as I mentioned you know in
this case we have every phone triggers
on average four times a day when you
have a lot of spurious triggers
periodically you create a false event we
see that with shake alert as well the
traditional seismic network so doing a
better job of recognizing that this is
actually an earthquake I picked this one
because it's not a high quality data
it's not poor quality data you know the
signal to noise of the p-wave is to the
signal to noise of the s-wave is maybe
five doing a better job of recognizing
that that's an earthquake and not a bus
clearly will make a big difference and
then the other piece of course is
associating these clusters of events the
reality is we don't know if Africa who
asked the question we don't really know
how well our real-time detection
algorithm is working right now just
because we've not yet had the chance to
really assess that
clearly it's not going to be working
very well and very confident of that and
so quite what the path forward would be
but we need to do a better job of being
able to recognize these earthquakes when
it comes to early warning it's about
being able to use as fewer stations as
possible as close to the epicenter as
possible and what's interesting where as
i was putting this together it's exactly
the same two questions whether we're
talking about shake alert or my shake we
actually have a postdoc right now whose
job with motor with shake alert is to
develop an earthquake classifier for the
traditional network right very similar
perhaps to the earthquake classifier we
developed for my shake so it doesn't
matter whether it's the high quality
data the low quality data it's the same
same kind of challenges of better
earthquake detection and then a better
clustering analysis that we need but
obviously the potential here for what we
can do is is really very exciting I you
know today of all days it's a nice day
to show this slide because as I said the
governor's about to sign the budget
which will be the first california
public funding Congress actually started
funding a public early warning system in
the US two years ago we've had two
rounds of funding from Congress and the
president put his support behind this
earlier this year also in February
actually by hosting an event at the
White House to promote shake alert so I
can stand here actually today is is very
different and actually say I'm very
confident that we will have a public
earthquake early warning system on the
west coast of the US in a few years
because the funding is coming the
network exists so that's coming so
that's good of course it could be better
but it's definitely coming and then of
course with my shake if we can you know
push this through to its conclusion we
could potentially be doing this all
around the world and so that I want to
draw a clear line though shake alert I
call a proven technology my shake is a
research project so that's a very
important distinction that I think every
way
understands okay thanks very much they
happy to take questions yeah are you
just consider lobbying the California
terriers to put it on cell towers
because you have just the density
mentioned earlier 300-400 squad colonic
most hotels on that increase you mean
the detection out with and put it on
cell towers knowing those guys are just
fearful yeah yeah they're surprisingly
difficult to persuade to do anything
including for example delivering alerts
from shake alert we have talked to cell
phone companies about doing a whole
variety of things and we've gotten
nowhere deutsche telekom of course it's
sort of you know it's the it's the
parent of t-mobile but even though
deutsche telekom has gotten very
interested in the my sheikh project
getting that to translate to act actions
from t-mobile has been almost impossible
yeah back to stevens point if you
instead of just sending an alert just
send a short snippet of at least some
encoding of get recorded data and look
at the correlations across phones and
you could get 0 to improve the cat you
mean ok so you're saying you would
expect the waveforms to look similar on
multiple phones yeah so there's another
way don't want to sit by you know you
don't have to load five minutes you
upload 20 doubles 20 floats 20 floats
would be high level at the high level
representation of a signal you're
looking at it's a thing right before
your last classifier which is earthquake
or not yeah right if you upload that you
could you would do a lot better it
extract a seaman make sure i understand
you're not saying their way from the the
G the acceleration you're saying just
the characteristics of the difficulty
the value of the different
characteristics actually 10 very well
chosen does okay nice okay so it's a
low-dimensional embedding about and it's
whatever your network is already trained
against at some the last level it's
gonna come
10 make it a hundred doesn't matter but
that's a tiny little packet and then
used use the kind of coding techniques
that are used for speech coding I just
extract a small number of parameters of
the waveform yep and that will be enough
to be able to detect correlations across
cell phones probably very little data
and forget essentially I mean you make
this perfect yep sounds great don't go
anywhere I need to talk to you you to
use any time correlation between these
signals between the different phones
that kind of see the wave um we're not
right now that I'm part of the reason
for that is the timing so still the
timing the uncertainty in the timing can
be up to a second or two yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah then so they're not actually I
know this has been part of our learning
curve they're not particularly well
synced the up to a few seconds is the
ones that we believe I'll reasonably
well synced but we're still getting that
kind of variability we're still working
through the problems on though I'm gonna
but GPS if your GPS no no no no it's not
GPS so they use GPS right it takes time
your phone doesn't have its GPS all the
time if it did that battery would be
completely dead so but they don't okay
well no no no that even if your GPS the
GPS is on my phone right now but the
actual antenna is not trying to use the
GPS signal right so your phone makes
intelligent choices about when to go and
get that GPS signal and it but it then
takes some time to get the lock and etc
so for the trigger we can't wait for
that GPS lock that's the issue so that's
why we can't use GPS time
I could conjecture that the forward
clock synchronization you have is
because you're using android phones
seriously yeah no that's right if you
win two iphones i think you could
probably get on the order tenth of a
second that's an interesting point note
that makes complete sense one of the big
issues I mean we picked Android because
there's so many more android phones and
there are friends around the world
however the issue is exactly what you
pointed to there are also so many
different types of Android phones and so
that's one of issues all using the exact
same clock if you visit a very different
direction here but do you hope to learn
something about seismology yes thank you
I'm a seismologist so yes that was my
objective and instead I'm learning about
cell phones but no i mean so the kinds
of things that we think that we can
learn about right there's the very uh I
mean I work on earthquake early warning
so that's what motivated a lot of this
so clearly we could do earthquake early
warning with this but I also think that
we can understand much more about the
earthquake rupture for example the
understanding how they take that
magnitude eight simulation I showed you
at the beginning of the cartoon actually
understanding how that rupture
propagates along the fault plane the
energy that's associated with each part
of rupture we actually have very little
information because we have very little
data so that's an example of if we had a
rupture of course it would mean we'd
have to have a big rupture going right
through an urban environment right in
order to have the right kind of data but
we would learn a huge amount about
earthquakes same time we could learn a
lot about the buildings that were living
in yes we have good buildings but
there's a lot that's not knowing about
how buildings respond to earthquakes
imagine a skyscraper where you have you
know a hundred people on every single
floor recording the shaking you'll
actually be able to recover the normal
modes of the building things like that
you might be able to see how the normal
modes of a building change over time
because the building is being damaged by
earthquakes things like that so yes I
think there's a whole array of things
that that we could learn once but right
now it's about actually trying to build
the network I mean you know it's like
going back to when people were first
designed in creating seismic instruments
and you had to have good time and you
had to have accurate amplitudes and
that's where we're at right now yeah
absolutely so I actually have a I looked
at you my shake thing and it has a weird
statistic that the 1906 earthquake in
San Francisco is 7.9 but at our location
harris's it's a nine you have an
explanation oh no I know exact so it's a
first of all that which earthquake 1906
yeah so 1906 earthquake was the
magnitude 7.9 earthquake okay but what
it's telling you is that our location
the shaking intensity was nine right so
earthquake magnitude there's one number
for an earthquake is a magnitude 7.9 but
then the amount of shaking you
experience depends on where you are with
respect to the earthquake no no these
are different scales magnitude scale and
intensity scale so you absolutely right
the intensity can only you've been
higher closer to the fault but here it's
an intensity nine you see success okay
thank you